all right he was the world's top chess
player for 20 years he became a
pro-democracy activist and now a
co-author of the new book fight for
liberty defending democracy in the age
of Trump a true hero garry kasparov
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so Gary you are such a good person
to have here as America retreats from
liberal democracy because some
experience you do and it's it's it's
disheartening we thought a generation
and go when the Cold War ended that
things we're gonna turn out differently
I guess first of all could they have
could Russia have gone a different
direction than Putin or was he
inevitable long story
yeah and it's that story I think we
should talk now while the lessons we can
learn from this story and I think
everyone should recognize that democracy
is not for granted so is this your hair
fight for that somehow in everything is
this Trump elections very important
milestone because Americans understand
it's you know it's always in making it's
right it's the mechanism that have been
developed 204 years ago or so they're
getting rusty and it's very important
that you revisited and there's certain
even amendments you know it could be
reconsidered because again the end of
19th century people couldn't foresee
everything it's one of the best
documents ever written because they
could you know predict so many you know
terms of history but not everything and
it's now it's you know we have to look
at this again and the idea of the book
was just that's we between us we call
the Federalist Papers 2.0 it's just to
actually bring these values and tried to
adjust them to the to the demands of the
21st century
so Trump kind of a stress test for
democracy
it's the Trump selection press test his
re-election would be probably demise of
democracy I think so too and I have been
saying to anyone who will listen on the
show for as long as I can he's not going
to leave even if he loses the election
and I've heard maybe I finally have a
witness here who will agree with me look
he didn't result they had
no he didn't want to recognize results
of elections he had one he's doing it in
Florida now he's setting the table for
that that's just again we should even
credit if you make all the credit that's
how he succeeded in two years turning
bat into normal all of a sudden
something that we believe would be
unacceptable you know even a coffee
house debate now it's a part of
mainstream political battle brand and no
doubt he will not stop we haven't seen
the worst because he'll be fighting with
survival
look he's affection to all dictators in
my view based on his psychological envy
to them because he also want to be like
them so he wants to act without any
checks and balances that's why I guess
he was depressed by the results of these
elections because all of a sudden now he
could be checked but again this the
presidential power is so vast and we
have to agree that in a little last few
decades probably after Watergate we
could see the accumulation of more and
more power and Oval Office and by the
way Trump selection was another warning
that many things many loopholes had to
be closed we have to look at the
presidential power and at the checks and
balances and to to recognize that again
we did a very poor job predicting
trouble so and and now it's time to
prepare for 2020 because I've no doubt
that he will fight his tooth and nail
and what we saw in this midterm prepared
force and what happens if he doesn't go
what do you think happens to the world I
don't think it's it's it's not about him
staying there if he loses it's about the
price this country will pay but what's
even more important is the is the image
of America worldwide because what trauma
gets succeeded in doing is is is ruining
the image of America being you know just
a it's a true democracy because all of a
sudden you see the man who acts like
inaudible Putin or other or you know
fellow dictators well I want to read
this quote and I've read it before on
the show it's Paul Ryan they caught him
on a mic he didn't know he was being
taped okay with Kevin McCarthy who was
now their leader and McCarthy says
there's two people I think Putin pays
Rohrbacher and Trump
swear to God and Ryan says this is off
the record
no leaks right this is how we know we're
a family here chilling mafia like it's
not like Paul Ryan says oh my god you
think Trump is on the payroll of
prehnite achieve the results of the
allegro bar in Orange County because he
lost a comment was that is it that's its
first election first elections that
Putin lost fair and square
well that's the thing I mean if anybody
Putin was gonna get involved in it would
be the election or bra Bracker if people
don't know who he is they call him
Putin's congressman congressman the
biggest fundraising event was organized
by Erik Prince yeah yes so yes it's more
than twenty thousand dollars was raised
for for Obama and believe there were
other rushing rushing connections that
haven't used to prop him up he's been on
our show many times stay in a rubber I
can ice guy traitor but a very
you